grenzen mitten in deutschland diese
bilder haben uns heute erreicht es sind
die bilder des tages sind absurde und
bedrückende bilder und zwar sehen wir
hier an der grenze zwischen brandenburg
und mecklenburg vorpommern also mitten
in deutschland grenzkontrollen wo
urlauber passanten bürger aus dem
verkehr gezogen werden und dort
kontrolliert werden und man analysiert
ob sie erlaubt sind in das bundesland
mecklenburg-vorpommern einreisen zu
dürfen
wir sehen hier verschiedene fahrer die
ihre ausweise dokumente vorzeigen müssen
und von dem polizeibeamten kontrolliert
werden
statt also zu hause zu bleiben zieht es
trotz ausgangs beschränkung viele von
brandenburg nach mecklenburg vorpommern
viele urlauber viele leute die dort ihre
ferienhäuser haben unser bild reporter
peter thiede ist im dorf kafr witz denn
dort findet eine direkte grenze zwischen
brandenburg und mecklenburg vorpommern
statt 1,5 kilometer hinter der grenze
ist dass brandenburg thomsdorf und kurz
davor kafitz und die leute fragen sich
natürlich kommen sie jetzt noch rein und
raus peter wir wollen natürlich von dir
wissen was passiert wenn du einige meter
weiter richtung mecklenburg vorpommern
vordringlich dass man direkt an der
grenze meter drin in mecklenburg
vorpommern aber wir sind uns sinti heute
leute begegnet die aus brandenburg mit
dem fahrer darüber gekommen sind
fahrradfahren darf man hier noch aber
ihre nachbarn konnten die tanken fahren
oder konnten nicht einkaufen fahren da
wurde supermarkt ganze vier kilometer
weg ist von den dörfern oder die nächste
tankstelle sie müssen stattdessen nach
brannenburg reinfahren und während die
leute sind natürlich total platt weil
hier da wo ich stehe dürfen keine
berliner sein gräber am wochenende und
auch heute morgen das ordnungsamt und
die polizei unterwegs und haben
kontrolliert ob ihr berliner sind oder
auswärtige sind die hier nicht sein
dürfen und die aufgefordert dann auch
das dorf zu verlassen
anderthalb kilometer weiter in
brandenburg ein völlig anderes bild dort
sind die ferienhäuser voll also
zumindest die ferienhäuser die den
leuten dort selbst gehören trotzdem
berliner brandenburger oder auch
schleswig holsteiner egal wo sich aus
deutschland herkommen
sie dürfen ja nicht nach mecklenburg
reinfahren aber wenn ihnen ein haus 100
kilometer weiter gehört dann dürfen sie
corona fällen auf dem lande machen
es ist völlig absurd aber wenn man den
leuten erklärt womit das begründet wird
nämlich dass zum beispiel mecklenburg
sagt naja wenn jetzt alle
hunderttausende leute die aus ganz
deutschland bei uns ferienhäuser oder
ferienwohnungen haben jetzt hierher
kommen und ihr corona frei machen und
dann bei uns corona ausbricht richtig
doll ausbricht dann schafft dass unser
gesundheitssystem nicht wenn man das den
leuten erklärt dann haben sie
einigermaßen verständnis es gibt völlig
absurde bilder hier zum beispiel haben
uns auch einige nachbarn hier erzählt
dass einige berliner ihre autos sind in
den scheunen hier verstecken sich in
form und das sind in den häusern
verbarrikadieren und einheit quasi dann
ihre quarantäne machen und diese häuser
nicht verlassen
aber halt nicht in die städte zurück
wollen die haben sich ja wirklich
versteckt ganz zu uns auch etwas über
die anwohner erzählen wir gehen die dann
mit diesem ganzen versteckspiel um
ja es ist wirklich unterschiedlich weil
es gibt leute die in ihr verständnis
haben die und sagen meine bitte lasst
die leute doch hier in ihren ferien
häusern seien aber dann haben wir mit
einer krankenschwester gesprochen hier
aus dem ort die und sagte na ja also wir
haben wirklich viele alte leute hier wir
sind mitten auf dem flachen land ihre
sind naturgemäß mehr alte leute weil die
jungen weg gegangen sind und die müssen
wir irgendwie schützen wenn jetzt aus
ganz deutschland leute anreisen hier in
ihre häuser gehen und dann von daten
lieber corona mitbringen dann ist das
für uns ein problem dann schaffen dass
unsere kliniken nicht und wir müssen uns
ja auch ein bisschen selber schützen
jeder muss jetzt mal vernünftig seien
sowieso die krankenschwester jeder muss
sein jeder muss zu hause bleiben sie
wäre auch lieber an der ostsee schöne an
der steilküste oben um auf usedom da hat
sich auch nicht hin und da kann sie auch
nicht auch nicht hin warum soll den halb
deutschland danach mecklenburg reisen
und ihr corona fällen machen
aber wie gesagt das ist der widerspruch
ist die leute können nicht mehr zum
einkaufen fahren können tanken fahren
sie werden permanent konnten
kontrolliert als sie können auch die
alltäglichen sachen teilweise nicht mal
der kleine grenzverkehr mitten in
deutschland wird ausgebremst
er beschreibt das ganze als grenze sind
wie gestaltet sich das dann konkret an
der grenze gehen die leute mit diesen
kontrollen friedlich um gab es das schon
reibereien die gipser jetzt schon seit
dem wochenende und am wochenende so
haben uns auch die polizisten erzählt
mit dem er unterwegs von heute morgen
und auch und auch gestern tagsüber sagen
zum anfang gab es ein bisschen zu sagen
das ist unverständnis jetzt kennt man
sich schon also man grüßt sich schon
weil die leute haben die die ganzen
pendler die morgens an morgens um sieben
werden kontrollen aufgebaut und gehen
ein paar stunden dann packt die polizei
ein dann kommt irgendwann wieder und man
hat sich jetzt darauf eingestellt und
die leute hier auf dem dorf sagen der
gott also wenn auf der straße kontrolle
ist wir kennen die waldwege wir kennen
die anderen regeln zur not kommt man
rüber aber trotzdem ist das
unverständnis auf seite der
brandenburger die jetzt plötzlich nicht
mehr drüber kommen ist riesengroß werden
folgen auch einen bauern der wollte nur
seinen großen trecker tanken kann zum
trecker tanken liegt einfach überfahren
der muss jetzt wie 15 kilometer weiter
fahren
das macht das leben komplizierter auf
der anderen seite haben wir auch
komplizierte zeiten wir haben keine
einfachen zeiten und jeder ist ja auch
gehalten im internet zu hause zu bleiben